(audience clapping)
- We always like to close out
with something super cool
we found on social media,
and just like everywhere else,
there is no shortage of
love for Dolly online.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(dynamic music)
(audience cheers)
I always appreciate how inventive teachers
can get with their classes.
There's one national elementary teacher
who uses Dolly Parton's life and songs
to teach all sorts of important lessons
to shape kids' lives.
No wonder she's been named
a Music Teacher of Excellence
by the Country Music Association
three times.
We have this educator
on the line right now
watching on NewsChannel
5 Nashville at three.
Hi, Alice.
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Kelly.
- What's up? So how did you,
first of all thank you
for being an educator.
You are an angel for doing that
but how did you come up with this?
- Well, I'm originally from New Jersey
and I grew up with samba
and classical music in my house,
so country folk was not something
I really was familiar with,
and when I moved in 2015 to Nashville,
I started seeing lots of
Dolly Parton everywhere and I heard
about her and her generous donation
with the Gatlinburg fire,
and I just thought, "Wow, what a person,"
and the more I got to know her
and learned about her story,
I realized she was a great
role model for our students.
A lot of what Dolly
talks about in her songs
is what the students
are thinking and feeling
and it just really creates a place
for them when they sing her
songs and listen to them.
- I mean, it's so wonderful.
I get it, even as a kid I related that way
'cause I don't come from, you know,
I come from humble beginnings,
so it was like, but she kind of made kids
think and feel like we
could accomplish anything.
We could make it because she did.
And so how are the kids
impacted by your Dolly lessons?
- A lot of them can really connect.
Turns out a lot of their
family members love Dolly too,
so the next week they'll say
like, "You know, I went home.
I shared about my lesson and we had
family singing of Dolly Parton.
We had a dance party.
We got to read the books."
And she just really brings the literacy
into the homes to encouraging the reading
with the parents and the children
and just their relatives,
but students really
see a little bit of themselves in Dolly,
and they take it with them
when they do their own songwriting,
and they can really feel
like they have a place
where they can express their
emotions and their dreams,
just like how Dolly did.
- Oh, I love that.
Thank you so much Alice.
(audience applauds)
This is such a cool way
to teach kids.
I'm liking your post right now.
(emoji dings)
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those creating
and teaching fearlessly just like you,
so they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience claps and cheers)
- Okay. (laughs)
I love it.
- Thank you so much, Allison.
(audience cheers louder)
Thank you.
A huge thank you to Dolly Parton
for spending the whole hour with us.
I love her so much.
Love her even more now.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, well try and change it.